bonjour verra la russie envisage-t-elle
l'autorisation d'autres vaccins sur son
sol bonjour emilie la reconnaissance
bilatérales des vaccins contre le
rotavirus est à l'ordre du jour a
affirmé le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov
les autorités russes espèrent que le
dialogue avec l'union européenne
permettra de trouver des solutions dans
ce domaine cependant il n'est pas encore
question de livraisons de vaccins
étrangers en russie je vous propose
d'écouter la piste d'une reconnaissance
bilatérales des vaccins est à l'ordre du
jour en ce moment nous espérons que le
dialogue avec l'union européenne nous
permettra tout de même d'aborder cette
question est de trouver des solutions
cependant jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas
encore de résultats tangibles
mais bien entendu cette question devra
encore être abordée nos propres vaccins
nous suffisent nous en avons quatre cela
ne fournit-il pas un éventail de choix
suffisant
à un moment donné ils peuvent cesser
d'être disponible mais dans l'ensemble
l'approvisionnement est assez régulier
jusqu'à présent cette question du
recours à des vaccins étrangers n'a pas
été évoqué sur fond de crise sanitaire
la russie rétabli ses liaisons aériennes
avec la france à partir du 24 juillet
l'annoncé de la reprise des vols après
une pause de plus d'un an est tombé le
14 juillet l'entrée sur le territoire
russe est conditionnée à un test pcr
négative de -2 72 12 heures à la russie
a repris à ce jour le service aérien
avec 48 pays après avoir fermé ses
frontières aux étrangers dès le
printemps 2020 pour contrer l'épidémie
quant à la cour des contaminations et là
on peut freiner sa rose plus de 25 mille
cas ont été détectés en russie ces
dernières 24 heures dont plus de 5000 à
moscou pour ce qui est du nombre des
décès c'est la troisième journée
consécutive des tristes records 791
morts ont été enregistrés aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup on verra goffman pour
toutes ces précisions depuis moscou
merci à vous